Singapore designates a a unesco creative
city of design in 2015 and we are very
proud to be a part of a network of 31
cities of design the Singapore Design
Council is it delighted to host 33
delegates from 15 fellow UNESCO creative
cities of design for the 2019 Singapore
designer during that time here we've
organized a special program for visitors
to experience key highlight activities
of the design week and also a public
forum for the cities of design to share
their programs and engage the wider
public and discussions around design
through the visit we've not only been
able to engage in all the sharing and
dialogue by the cities have also widened
their circle of friends and we're on the
wall I can look forward to the more
collaborations and partnerships
organization like this that we are doing
now in Singapore
and the rest of the organization around
the world is so good for other units for
creative cities the best thing is we are
coming together and creating new ideas
and new projects together this time I
will study many things from Singapore
and the other cities of design
[Music]
one of the most meaningful experiences
that I had here was the first night at
dinner we were eating at a local
restaurant having local cuisine at
Beaufort and I was sitting at a table
with people from all around the world
other UNESCO delegates and we realized
that we were having very similar
initiatives thinking about the future of
design practice so thinking about the
year 2025 and what current designers but
also my student with their jobs feels
like in the future so what does being a
member of the UNESCO creators that it
means Dundee who joined in 2014 because
we wanted to be more internationally
connected and in that period it provided
opportunities for Dundee to connect with
other global cities like Singapore and
it's also provided opportunities for
young designers in the city to be more
exposed internationally and we see it
probably as a learning journey I think
there is a really need to learn from
each other
Helsinki is really keen in this
phenomenon based learning and
multidisciplinary learning that we could
do together some kind of teacher
exchanges so networking is really
important because we have commonalities
like you know creativity is within all
of our human beings that we need to tap
into it and I look into the ways of how
we can put the creative thinking in
schools in different countries and in
different systems
[Music]
when Loom and Singapore actually are the
first Southeast Asian cities within the
city of design of UNESCO credit cities
network so our similarities of course
that we are both from Southeast Asia we
have our similar challenges in weather
climate change and so on we also have
our challenges in population then we
also have our differences which makes it
interesting for us to learn from each
other
Singapore design which gives us really a
good opportunity to look into what we
can work together forward in the near
future I think that even Singapore have
many things in common related to design
but maybe the most important one is that
the two cities had a Arminius from Asian
driving my design
[Music]
- want to say thank you so much for
Singapore because some nice experience
for me and I learned a lot of things
from as a city's case studies and young
trying to do designer so I want to bring
back to who we are my experiences and I
don't forget my memory of Singapore
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]